moviegoers can trust the Transformers
franchise to deliver plenty of Carnage
on a blockbuster scale but the films
aren't exactly critical Darlings the
rise of the Beast change all that
Transformers rise to the Beast features
a star-studded voice cast that includes
the academy award-winning Michelle yo
the story sees the titular
shape-shifting robots team up with the
maximals for a pulse-pounding adventure
but will the latest sequel fare better
than previous flicks or will it be
dismissed as just another loud messy
action movie the good news is that rise
of the Beast isn't the worst installment
to the series according to Rotten
Tomatoes as of the making of this video
the Stephen cable Jr directed actioner
is somewhere in the mid 60s to low 70s
depending on when you see this making it
one of the most well-received franchise
outings to date Owen gleberman a variety
praised the movie for being more
grounded than previous Transformers
flicks writing it's got a relatable
human story that works and thanks to a
script that actually has sustained
bursts of dialogue the robots felt more
real to me as characters than they
usually do this is probably a lot for
you huh at the same time this is still a
Transformers movie which means some
reviews are guaranteed to be negative
the latest installment has already
garnered its fair share of detractors
while the Rotten Tomatoes rating
suggests that the fan fans currently
outweigh the naysayers with that in mind
let's examine what the critics are
saying about rise of the beasts the
positive reviews of Rise of the bee
share the consensus that it's a fun time
at the movies furthermore unlike
previous films about the Autobots and
Decepticons the franchise's seventh
installment has plenty of heart to
complement the machine-driven Carnage
Frank Sheck of The Hollywood Reporter
believes that rise of the Beast will
entertain long-term fans especially
those who grew up playing with the toys
that paved the way for the movies
cartoons video games and other media
check wrote These Hasbro action figures
and their on-screen incarnations are
capable of reducing even the most mature
jaded adults into an awestruck child who
just wants to get down on the floor and
play with them elsewhere comicbook.com
reviewer Liam Crowley was impressed with
the action set pieces in the film's
entertainment value writing the action
is pulse pounding the summer movie
season has been in Full Throttle for
just over a month and Transformers rise
of the Beast sends out popcorn
Blockbuster momentum into full gear
Stephen cable Jr's direction also
receives some positive feedback from
critics with uprox noting that he shows
a genuine affection for the characters
it goes a long way the reviewer also
gave the movie props for including some
memorable 90s needle drops so viewers
can expect a bang soundtrack while the
positive reviews tease a heartfelt
action adventure movie some of the
naysayers believe that rise of the Beast
is unremarkable for example Valerie
complex of deadline Crazy Action
sequences while arguing that the story
is nothing to write home about rise of
the Beast is another generic story about
an Intergalactic Menace from the sky
that carries all the plot predictability
of a broken clock Indie wire reviewer
Christian Zilker offered a more scabian
evaluation of the film stating that it's
just another soulless Blockbuster which
is a bad look now that movies based on
toy brands are evolving Zilker wrote
it's as if some Executives saw Mattel
and Greta Gerwin turning Barbie into
genuine art so they made a George
Costanza style decision to be here in
the opposite direction purely out of
spite Charles bermesco of the Guardian
echoed these sentiments and highlighted
some issues with the film's script
writing that the film might confuse
viewers who aren't familiar with the
series everything has a vague partial
finish as if director Steve cable Jr and
the five-person Brain Trust responsible
for the script banked on the audience's
familiarity with the shape of a movie to
fill in the gaps they've left curious if
rise of the Beast rises above the
franchise's less than Stellar reputation
the latest Transformers installment hits
theaters on June 9th